in this video I want to further our
discussion of the pentose phosphate
pathway and talk specifically about
NADPH and glutathione and how they act
as antioxidants and how the pentose
phosphate pathway is involved so we said
that the pentose phosphate pathway makes
NADPH and we said that NADPH provides
reducing power now what did we say that
reducing power was useful for we said it
was useful for biosynthesis but it's not
just important for biosynthesis it can
also be used to protect biomolecules
from oxidants now what are oxidants
they're oxidizing agents is just another
term for them oxidants oxidize things
okay now why are they relevant is
because oxidants can destroy
biomolecules our cells are made up of
biomolecules if they're destroyed cells
die if cells die the organism dies so
this is why this is relevant RIF not
relevant or irrelevant so how does this
actually happen how does NADPH how is it
involved in acting as an act antioxidant
well you call them this dude called
glutathione
okay so glutathione of course by dude I
mean a molecule so good fire is a
tripeptide containing cysteine so
tripeptide means is made up of three
amino acids right tri meaning three so
good if I own looks like this I want you
to look over here on the right first so
it's made up of three amino acids of
glutamate cysteine and glycine and I
haven't drawn in the R groups for Luda
Goethe Mae or glycine I really want you
to focus on cysteine so notice here I've
written reduced glutathione and GSH GSH
over the short shortened version for we
just go to file is basically G with the
file group so assisting ZAR group this
thio group here has this H here so we
know that this is the reduced form it
can be oxidized and form a disulfide
bridge so if we take two of them two of
these and we oxidize it go this way to
the left so we create oxidized
glutathione
which is two G's right and then these
the two S's here
represent this disulfide bridge forming
so this is the oxidized form so
basically what happens is that
glutathione takes one for the team what
do I mean by that when glutathione is in
its reduced form it can be oxidized
right so if an oxidant comes in an
oxidizing agent comes in reduce go to
file and we'll say okay cool let let me
get oxidized instead of these other
important biomolecules so reduce
glutathione will get oxidized and turn
into oxidized glutathione okay so
that'll keep happening to protect us
from oxidants so if an oxidant comes
along then the the gsh right the reduced
glutathione will take the blow and it
will get oxidized and become oxidized
glutathione now if lots of oxidized
oxidizing agents come along lots of
oxidants what would happen well that
means we'd have more gsh right this
reduced glutathione get oxidized this
oxidized form this glutathione this
oxidize go to fly on so we'd have a
bunch of gsh being oxidized into GS SG
okay so what if this keeps happening if
there are a bunch of oxidants they turn
all of our GS h into GS SG so now
there's no more reduced go to file left
to protect us from the cells
biomolecules there's no GS h left to
protect cells biomolecules
that's a bad thing okay so how do we
solve this well we need to find a way to
take this oxidized glutathione and
remake this reduced glutathione so we
must reduce the oxidized form of
glutathione with an ATP h oops we do
the GS SG with reducing power which is
of course NADPH
so how does that actually happen this
oxidized glutathione it's if a lot of
its oxidized we have NADPH come in
provide the reducing power so NADPH will
reduce the glutathione and the
glutathione oxidizes the NADPH so the
NADPH will come out as nadp+ and then we
get the reduced with the phione now it's
available to protect us this this step
is catalyzed by glutathione reductase so
this step is catalyzed by glutathione
reductase so basically what's happening
is that NADPH allows the the the
reduction of the oxidized buddha found
to regenerate reduce codify in to keep
us able to fight off and fight off these
oxidants okay so that's how NADPH and
gluta final work together to fight
oxidants I hope that video is helpful
thank you for watching
hey folks my name is mo food I am a
tutor I graduated from UC Riverside with
a degree in biology and on graduation
they had a little bit of trouble with
the wind miss you can tell the subject
that suited for our listed here in the
description below you'll find my email
address if you have any questions and
you'll also find the links to two
listings my university tutor listing
which is for in-person tutoring and my
Google helpouts listing which is for
online tutoring thanks for watching